[Musik]
so jetzt tun wir die Oliven ernten und
zwar tue ich unten wenn ich ein bisschen
kleiner bin mit dem mit diesem Kamm hier
tue ich jetzt alles schön durchkämmen
wird alles per Hand gemacht außer der
große Schüttler das ist so ein
elektroschüttel das macht der Günni er
ist zertifizierter baumschnittler er
macht es dann und das Besondere ist auch
dass wir die Oliven tagsüber ernten ich
weiß dass es in manchen Regionen auf der
Welt auch nachts geerntet wird weil es
heißt dass die Oliven die nachts
geerntet werden besser sind es ist aber
an Irrglaube stehen absolut nicht und
das Problem ist dass viele viele
Singvögeln nachts in den ganzen Bäumen
drin sind und dann qualvoll verenden und
das machen wir nicht wir machen jetzt
nur tagsüber und wie gesagt ich mache
unten unter Günni oben
[Musik]